question party is very simple okay so
you guys in the audience are going to
ask me and tara questions and then we
are going to answer them yeah and it's
going to be fun like a party and if you
have a question just raise your hand and
if we call on you stand up and ask it
and ask it nice and loud so that we can
hear you yeah but don't pull your mask
down we want you uh we want to answer
your questions and not uh you know
spread aerosol droplets
okay so let's do this i see some hands
do you see some ants come on hi you're
waving at me
[Music]
so my question is about your friendship
it's clear that you guys are so happy
and such positive spirits can you talk
about the last time you guys got into an
argument
me and tarek arguing
uh amber doesn't argue she stabs
and that kind of ends it
you know so it's just like i don't know
my app
all right you're right and that's it
uh really
argument uh now
if it's like
cereal
what's the best yeah
we will argue about dumb stuff yes we
will like draw swords was that peebo
bryson or was it you know uh babyface
babyface yeah that's a fight
yeah and no one's picking up their phone
google it whoever googles it is a punk
we will
and i will know i'm wrong but i'll be
like i'm right on this it was it was
jeffrey osborne it was people bryson it
was people bryson and you know it yeah
this man but yeah we don't sorry it's
we're so i mean maybe if there maybe if
it wasn't coveted then i could
physically fight you yes
uh but yeah like every time we're here
together this is such an amazing
experience you know we're just so giddy
and happy today that's true it's because
this is a delight yes now if it was us
back at boom chicago yes doing a show we
worked at theater club bloom chicago in
amsterdam where we did corporate shows
all over europe for many many people
whose second or third or not language
was english well we could reenact an
argument from boom chicago days yeah so
all something would have to happen
because you saw each other every day
every single day and you had to work
every day
every night and if that first year
we didn't speak the language so we saw
each other in every space so this would
just cause an argument hey amber why are
you touching me i hate your guts i hate
you why don't you die it's my parents
i'm so sorry
so that's real yeah that was real that's
real
who's way in the back red shirt
hi hey my name is glenn and what is your
favorite form of potato glenn said what
is your favorite form of potato yes
you about to start a war
glenn
glenn
what i am about to say you're not going
to like
my favorite form of potato and this is
real mm-hmm i'm not making [ __ ] up to
stir [ __ ] this is just the best kind of
potato
i'll grotten oh no sorry sister screamed
out no crazy no
no
how did that happen lacey
i love how ground potatoes i love them i
love them oh that is like
i know i'm wrong but i also my mouth is
right it tastes so good oh they're the
worst you're the worst yeah you're the
worst i hate it oh my gosh i'm so sorry
what is the best potato i mean
i'm being real black but potato salad
like
wild i'm not thinking to the two black
people
i didn't wait she's like come on i'm
like
we and your sister we understand i
didn't think of potato salad yeah i
would rather have potato salad than all
ground vegetables
it's cold so i didn't think about it i
just thought hot potatoes ah man that it
is potatoes in it it is salad
and a bunch of
sugar and it's delicious it is it is
delicious and terrible for you can you
make potatoes out um cherry can cook a
little bit can you cook potato salad by
cook i mean mixed together
i can it's not so my grandmother had he
made she was she was uh she cooked for
the longshoremen in virginia and her
potato salad was like famous in all of
virginia and she would not share the
recipe
what so she passed away she's like she
was my i loved her but she i was like
grandma what's this recipe she'd be like
um
[Music]
she wouldn't tell me and now you still
don't know i still don't know no one
knows i'm convinced it was crack
you guys
that's the point of question party put
crack in your potatoes all right that's
all the time we have this was great
should we do it again
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign